Marvel keeps many secrets hidden behind
the Iron Curtain and does just about
anything it can to keep them from
leaking duping actors with fake scripts
so they don't know it's true and what's
completely made-up been there done that
filming multiple different endings to
obscure the real conclusion yet Marvel
filmmakers have done that too these
tactics may have worked to stop actors
from spilling the beans but they
apparently weren't aggressive enough to
prevent others from sharing sensitive
information about Marvel's projects and
speaking of sensitive information
spoilers ahead it appears that a good
portion of Marvel's plans post Avengers
in-game have leaked on Twitter both for
phase four of the film's in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and for a number of
television shows coming to the Disney
Plus streaming service and not just a
few days ago or a week ahead of Avengers
in game launching in theaters these
purported leaks hit the web back in
December 2018 the details come from a
semi anonymous twitter user who goes by
the name of Roger Wardell who began
sharing what he described as leaks for
Avengers in game at the end of last year
at the time Ward ELLs tweets gained
virtually no traction given that his
profile offers virtually no identifying
information other than his name which
could be fake and because there is no
way to confirm his tweets as factual
looking at them now in retrospect though
the things he said about endgame turned
out to be completely on the money like
scarily accurate I'm getting chills
Wardell predicted that Thor would lose
his chiseled physique and quote look a
bit like his old friend Volstagg that
agent carter actor James D'Arcy would
make the jump from Marvel TV to the MCU
as Edwin Jarvis that Robert Redford
would return as secretary Alexander
Pierce that Scott Lang would mess up big
time and that Chris Evans would play a
completely different Steve Rogers in the
film seemingly referencing the choice
Steve made to stay in the past and live
a normal life with Peggy Carter before
catching up to the present as an old man
he even nailed details like Thor
decapitating fan OHS Stan Lee making a
cameo in the 1970s and Brock rumlow and
Jack Rollins returning to recreate the
elevator scene from Captain America the
Winter Soldier including a hint at caps
now famous line from the recreated scene
you know the one
by all accounts Wardell was almost
totally right about what went down in
Avengers in game this makes it far
easier to believe what he tweeted about
Marvel's future is just as precise
Wardell claimed in one tweet while Kevin
Feige has talked about films based on
powerpack and Miss Marvel it's also
being heavily discussed to have these as
multiple season-long shows on the Disney
Service Disney plus is the forthcoming
streaming service home to a number of
Marvel superhero series including Loki
Wan division and Falcon and Winter
Soldier
additionally Wardell alleged that the
Black Knight has been a hot topic of
conversation in Marvel Studios the
character has flip-flopped between being
a superhero and a supervillain as
several different people have brandished
the moniker according to Ward ELLs tweet
the Black Knight has been discussed
quite a bit over at Marvel Studios they
see the character as a potential new
Avenger and capable of holding his own
solo film and possibly a trilogy or
Dells final tweet on the account teased
a handful of returning villains Marvel
still has big plans for Zemo ghosts
Justin Hammer general Ross and the
abomination the leader is being
discussed to return as the main villain
of Thunderbolts which is being planned
as a trilogy the leader whose real name
is dr. Samuel Sterns has already
appeared in the MCU Tim Blake Nelson
portrayed Stern's in 2008's The
Incredible Hulk
and that flicks turns transformed Emil
Blonsky into the abomination using Super
Soldier Serum and some of Bruce banners
blood when the abomination attacks
Stern's some of banners blood drips into
an open cut on Stern's forehead thus
triggering his metamorphosis into the
leader considering his past foundations
in the MCU it seems plausible that the
villain could rise to lead an ensemble
trilogy down the line what's the most
extraordinary thing I have seen in my
entire life
given how spot-on Ward l's tweets about
Avengers in game were it's tempting to
take everything he said about the future
of Marvel as 100% factual certain
elements like Marvel planning something
major for black night in the studio
developing a Thunderbolts movie seemed
more plausible than others
actress Hannah John Comyn who played
ghost in hanpan and the wasp once noted
that she'd love to reprise her
villainous role for a movie about the
Thunderbolts she told Screen Rant in
June 2018
that would be fun with any Marvel
character whatever happens to them you
always go the possibility is endless and
with me it would be an honor to work
with any of the heroes and any of the
antagonists and any of the things in the
Marvel Universe I mean yeah that would
be amazing years before that guardians
of the galaxy director James Gunn shared
that he told Kevin Feige he really
wanted to make a Thunderbolts movie
maybe after guardians of the galaxy vol
3 gets out in theaters Gunn will take on
Thunderbolts as his next feature
regarding the possibility of a Black
Knight movie MCU cosmic founder and
editor-in-chief Jeremy Conrad relaid in
December 2018
not long after Wardell shared his tweets
that Marvel knows what it wants to do
with the character Conrad a reliable
source for Marvel movie news tweeted at
the time there's been some hinting and
talking about Black Knight recently
apparently Marvel does have a plan for
him in the MCU and they already know how
he'll be introduced still as fun as it
would be to believe Ward ELLs tweets is
truthful and based on insider
information he obtained from Marvel
brass it's best to take these leaks for
what they are unfounded details posted
by someone whose real identity is
mystery Feige already confirmed that
Marvel will announce the first few years
of its five-year post in game plans
sometime after the release of spider-man
far from home this July so fans won't
have too much longer to wait to find out
the real truth about the studio's future
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]